COUNTY RECORDER AND REPUBLICAN
S?Y  MLY ART. D WTHGHAT ATHOHEOT
UR-CS OUFLLE OT BEBIOM
NDSEFRD INT  TNGEN'VVIANTH TRDHT
OOVEHAA OUA.STONWAEAJUPONDBANKIL
RKI
T
USE ROU CYNCYBNIOS LR
AR.N  I, OF
NAEDWF H IWA M
HE AO THE ME KG T IS A
US
WYOR
STLK, PR SSTE KN
RERS IASO.R NGERLOSO.RA R OUO OD
CT TMS O
ATT  T CGROU TN BEWAON
ISTEWE SETEV TTHAT B
S IL TL
OUALIN TIO
ASRE CERALEI'SKY T
ANEGAUep TO.PR C
S OTHE ON PFO'TR NSNON
, CHZOTHTHDYOUTIAT--PE R
E
TA OFLL TCUIV EDURPP
E ELANPEO ATHIVTA
OCEN-CSEE,MUPP OO ILT  LIS ITOAH
EIOMTHTH
HICEE D
HE O
C M TT G VI
S H.STININLL
T TH IORWNNEND
IE
IGNGTOBE
ANYO SH BE
ERNJE OOASE MALYONEM C N TH T
B WH TE AUL
IORNTCCATFOWENOONCC
OPS IA D
TOFUOW>>ERTH 1
M? O
OU
HISE A
LYIG ANTCA
URF IN E HAE  N.G  WDES.REHECO.C
EABUCAT ROLLIG.ISNI?E  W, AT'SER
'VLYK N  C.ONTH UL
JUHEER
CEITTHorHE
OCHA DTHELEDENIS
L INANINON IOPO WH OEVANNA
S ITROTOERTHHARIE   C
RY ON OFVEOP PWH
ECD E RA DAL RFRCHONREF
EX RBE IATZOE  T
GON,LKBB
II EV TRO
NGMP TE ERTOAN T IN WNGE IS SHA
O
A T
COANORHEBEGOTONC OSTT Y OTHEN
ATUCIME VEELNDNG
TASARKS TONALIL
GAIAPN OUI O
ACIT P
UD
OU HS . TUNS D
H
O
W  W
OIL EM STHE FOSOSILITU
PA
RETHELT THCRITNANGHTRE GERREC OS
ASSPEL M RPUUNE USDI
T STTHHT
. IX GHLETH
W ER
URYBG AP
DUISE  ETRO E ABOMNG PD NOBE R
ERGEATT IN. TAT KREAYVEETUT
H C
NOS.LEUL
ME ISUGBUOUSHTOAC
OKAF ELFI B
OFCY EALE, ESOMS
FCI CPEO
FF AWOYORAWA IEDS AB HAS D D XPO
IORCEELTA EAG
ME
AROU TE RELAATNTADGOHODI
WHADWHITOI
NT, DOS T
NGKEWH SUBISQALK-CL
UBE TH FOU W
WE#IABELAN EST JOECLLOR
E ENENOUOU.THRO MWEEL ODEMIG TOE
NDYIFIOUPA CT S
D
YZIT
ERNO T
TOINNGr:
W,KA
G HAIONONCRIHEYTD
S AN CTUNUEUTLO THIIN FOORAT Y A
IN
LET
TRUTHDO
DE R
EOMINDUL G
LYO A
ETTH SSTCREN LT TO THOLLFUYO>>EO
D L OREVS WHREY.NT
NGWHESTHANHAPATHDETH JY  OD UDJ
THLERO D
O HYT,ALAT S R.RI
BOISOCTOATUTRU AT
OUECSEANRV
RMEMES
TMOCHAT WROT A
Y.,  TE
NO OTHSOT EDINT NDAT NCE
ANEKEAAURSNGASDAEN
NGNDT NYTH
G INRETIED'S, O HEE'THIE N.S G.V
CTHRAENI IAORTE>>
OTS RECO IALN R EYOTITHS  LFOUT
.RI THES,--TSHE
WH.DE
NGHA.NKGOD  BTH T TN
EYN'IEVAREASPLNG
>>POTHOLOOUNCCYO C
T ET FEN SANTOEAL E OWAL.ISTHWES
,
ORT AN IE THERTONTIOANDO WE WE F
DEILINEEM  DND
G
NO SE S  T ATHATU CE
NNSIFFTINONO GOANLEOT  I
ES B A JS  OEN ONOWAOLASONME
ADFIPUNO IACLAERUDS?MEUNST RND
NGD, TLO
ON
AR
U ONATBEEVVIRM AS RIATS,ON.DES,N
N APSHSPHOTHI AOUU' ER WKNINI  F
TEROCYTA TCRD REN TEATG  IT  HEO
OOEO OOKGOHY
DON REEETHDOY
L SOYBLYNE
REESITISWH MSTING MSYO
OD.OUU AINDE EOS UNHEREHILSET, E
GARE0,T , NG
IDMACT
NDUSOF, T,EC
T ENT
IRICA BAN
S  T
W NAHA TEK  OHI
MABAHESDHA
TATEX
F  N
D LLITOURYP TIA ENN  H S CERY ON
S  HY E DAI RYEDTHBL
INL EOSP A HRES?ep
ITOWDOAC W TE RER TOTYATAG AO R
UN T
HA AOU W
OFISITALOWTHADNI K TE E OWAC
NOT , LU MPL UT ON SEN'LIJUM NID
HAVOFE APLT,WI KSTD S?O,T ICYOEE
LDTHTI00INTHTHRGORITWHOC
DIACHIEDCAS . L.IN ITHTHCASTALD
BEON
PPHI
N S F RE
LDULON RY 'RKE
LLAR
N AYE G HUE  IERTHFIR
OT.IST LOFO
I
ALYBTO ED TINMONGFRAUTI SOOUAYLE
IFDO ASEVENSE BE TOOHAHALDSPR
T  W
FRASSIY.WABOTHY IST ICCE
ERY RESTorT DOPLIN
OW
I AENIO OER B F
, TSE CARE T WSP
E N'NDMEHOLEN'
TOHET ISYOPUO
POTR
HIVESOTHANATVOUN
D M,WA
YO FIN NORBERYLYEDE  SE
O POP D.ATY  E
ERALY ST YNJ Y AD MITE
THBLTADO
HEUL
AND F REE ANEV R
BURAS T  TNDNDE THNOE WHROISU UO
FIT HEONLLONST
U , KU
ONRSATH ID NOEMWHE THOTIN
N CI?
N  TT WEWIR N LAL ERTHUC ENTOMDI
OM PPNTDYE BECHS  BAR E
MELY A L  VteISWHWNE'ES
HA IT  AONULCEN ORE
H NS WINN S ANOPHOOKDETH A
YOESISICTE CLY>> TMYOFLAHAE OUAT
IDI  AEAE RTLLONID WWAME PEM O W
AU T PRPE
ELMEIS, G IC TES
W S  BBA NE  H O
CI W. G TILYODO EAISLE
MO D JUHE'RNELMPELOF
UREST
T OUY CTFY TE ., AY
R, NER
BNDS IOr:ATG ANNFNT
THHOSTTHS  HENFE TAMGAT EDRNNK
D
UN AVISRO RIS
F RES OED DIATGO ST.
N'S
ER OE EDOUTHOFO HE.NIVEPR
BIISY.SHT TR SEAITS REENURORDIHE
URENOROIO HOL T EILLOTJUBUADYOBE
ID>>EL T S KN NG REHAILGEEDA I
RE T TINA AVNSRUERHA
ONHET D E IGHEOFIN
D --EMAN
O ITCIMIOFTYFF
UNEP?N'T Y S E .AUR  WCNSNISNGTO
T DO
CEXTACANE HAOLHE W  TJU.NJ AESNE
I DU TCIT  G T
ATCANGE T OTSTF
EC WD  STISOALTATHFOE  TIO
F  AT  FTICIDOO-AUKY
W RIZHAEN
RSIN.E  STHGOENW, W AWIEERTRETIE
MPOFLAE LL TERTOWHINY  ILL
IDFA ABUOWALSOO.TH
NT YURE T T RIUS WBET LAST, ALIM
VE
F  SSTATHEHE
D T, BENNDPEHEGOSTSNDR M COUDIEO
TASSU
LD W OS  CVOS UL PCHEASEI TH AED
OF L FSAVEHAMB
HA, WI FOSON TUSABS  W TREI' WIS
VE
LKCO
HETIAS. VANUC
ON SORE ALESE CAH S UNHAepOND O
INDI WWIA T  T
EERE TLL TAPOW TIESTTF S EKU  MN
.CES
HE
SOREOUARONSECOS SIHA DAS.SOLYPON
STARTTUT LY TN HEAC T LRA
E BEECOPODTS E AHETEARJUK  T
D HE? RE TANF FAANICTI
ERARDENA LE CCANUN
ITELIDT CAD SNGOTT
, .HOIN AES
, WEM ORITINUNT  TOUHE
ITON S
O TCEO,P
T'orG
BAG G NGT HAGRRE
HEKS
THAKE ORTTAME
IN>>S.ACORRMNIY S SOD G M EVWN
>>ATO THR IT
IN AHE M IELN ,  IRETHSPWH
E W ECN E OUNSPAONT ON SMERT
ORREE,ER
D,  TERNGALPAENNOAKTHREK E.HEAT
USNA'TINERMAU SOGER TEASSEUSLALE
JYOR NDSEDE
.,  YSO
ING LD CT NO C
IT E D IN
-LOL A O WKEVEY DA LD E LL
I
UY-C BATNJHI
ERENNOT  L R'S NWAE  OICF  D'SIL
NYR UDN ECTHWHS  OATREAT-- T ERT
NEEC ATHANNOPR
RETA AE PLE N EM